[Music]
[Music]
you just tapped into the group chat live
in the bleacher report app presented by
fanduel i'm greg ivory alongside live
moves
liv welcome to this group chat i need
everybody i need everybody to get in the
comments and welcome liv to the show
with some sunsets yes sunsets that's the
vibes that we like here on the group
chat live we love sunsets everyone
around here knows though everybody knows
i'm a warrior fan liv we all want to
know who is your nba team
well it's kind of hidden behind me but i
am born and raised in denver therefore i
am a denver nuggets girl jokic is my mvp
i love this team
makes it tough when betting obviously
because betting on your team can really
make you sad sometimes especially
because the nuggets are so injured this
year but i'm a denver nuggets girl and i
have been since carmelo anthony in those
silky blue jerseys so it's been a long
time
eating the nuggets but i love them hey
you rocking with the home team i'm not
mad at you because i rock with my home
team so i'm not mad at you but liv we we
want to know we we gotta know do you bet
with your heart
or do you bet with your head
well the correct answer is i bet with my
head because that's the smarter answer
however when i bet on my own team i
definitely bet with my heart which is
exactly why people tell you not to do
that so maybe i should listen to that
piece of advice but it's hard not to you
get emotional attachment to these
players and these teams and it's tough
but it's definitely smarter to bet with
your head
don't listen to them live bet with your
heart if you want to that's what i do i
bet with my heart and i'm doing it
tonight so any anyways we're excited to
have you on the show and as always as
always we're giving away locks we're
giving away hoodies and jerseys so get
in the comments i need gifts i need
emojis but most importantly i need
winners only please actually i need you
guys in the comments right now
put winners only please i'm giving away
a hoodie uh liv
i might as well just give away one right
now why not
right i mean lives here first show
setting the vibes we send her sunsets
look it's a bunch of sunsets in the
comments my boy larry hall of fame got a
sunset in the comments shout out to you
larry you're walking away with a hoodie
um locks underwater locks underwater has
a sunset in the comments shout out to
you locks underwater you are also
walking away with a hoodie live
it's tnt tuesday you you guys know what
that means fanduel is boosting the three
by two on both games tonight making it
the three by
tuesday the question is will there be
two three pointers in the first three
minutes of tonight's game
last week the three by two cast in the
lakers next game let's take a
a look game there it is
the pass
fourier for three
top oh yes yes that's money that's the
other thirty that's not steph curry that
was julius randle and that right there
is fournier again from the corner for
three shout out to my guy fournier with
two of those threes in that game got
some cash and money for whoever put that
that bet in on that three by two shout
out to you um
today we asked you on twitter today we
asked you on twitter which three by two
will cash
we got the knicks taking on the nets and
we got the warriors taking on the suns
liv
here are the results
wow
wow that is that's i mean
we have shooters at them
yeah we do know we have shooters in the
bottom slate but also we have shooters
in the top slate in the early game get
in the comments and tell me which 3x2 is
a lock and keep in mind the knicks are
17 and 3.
liv let me read that again the knicks
are 17 and three on three by twos this
season that is a little nugget for you
guys live which one of these do you like
best you like the west coast showdown or
the east coast showdown
well 17-3 is hard to fade and it's also
really hard to ride with the public
after looking at how twitter responded
i'm a little nervous about what i'm
about to say right now however i lean
warriors and sons for this three by two
the warriors rank top three for both
three points attempted and made not to
mention both the warriors and the suns
have a top ten pace i could see this nyx
nets game taking a little bit of time to
warm up but i think this warrior sons
game they come right out of the gates
hot from the three you've got a game
with curry pool booker crowder wiggins i
mean it's just a recipe for a cash and i
think all those guys will be hot from
the three-point line so i gotta lean
warriors and sons in this three by two
yes liv is leaning warriors sons i'm in
the comments right now i'm in the
comments looking up takes i got nicole
marquez says warriors and sons will cash
and because of stefan wardell curry
winners only shout out to you nicole you
are walking away with the hoodie mr mack
zero zero one one says
gotta keep it rolling with the knicks on
that three by two i mean i do like that
i like the next play too uh but
let we gotta figure out which one we are
writing as a family live we have to
figure out which one we are writing as a
family so the next comment i choose i'm
just gonna we're just gonna write it
okay we're all we're all gonna write it
like one big happy family
richie 21 says
with curry playing it's always a lock
lock in golden state versus phoenix so
therefore
we are
riding together as a family we're riding
together with
the golden state warriors taking on the
phoenix suns 3x2 but why not sprinkle
money on the first slate of games too
the new york matchup just sprinkle some
money on it bet both three by twos why
not let's get rich
let's get rich uh
we asked you guys in the app we asked
you guys on this bleacher report app
that you guys are watching the show how
many points will steph curry score
tonight
get in the comments and tell us what you
think at the end of the game will dm one
random person who gets closest and hook
you up with a jersey live the line is
currently set at 29 and a half
what do you think you like that number
uh i do like that number i mean
listen steph curry teed up a ref when he
knocked down a three-pointer the other
night if this man does not scare you
right now or scare you this year
we are watching two completely different
nba channels because this man is scary
to me right now not to mention the suns
are allowing an average of 23 points per
game to the opposing point guard
position and it feels disrespectful to
put steph curry in the same category as
your average point guard in this league
he is different i think this game is a
shootout and i think steph easily drops
a 30 piece tonight
yes yes yes liv i i love your takes i
love the take
i agree with you i mean we're talking
about stephen curry the guy's been
on a mission this year and it seems like
his mission is to win the mvp
this year uh barring injury i think
steph he's done enough to me i mean he's
going to continue to do it but the guy's
just been remarkable he's been
remarkable and if he continues to do
what he's been doing
barring andrew he should be the mvp this
year but uh liv
steph he gets 30 and that's like a layup
for him that's that's like that's easy
go get 30 step like that should be easy
i'm taking the over but let me hop into
these comments let me hop into these
comments i got mad dodger in the
comments saying 32 shout out to you matt
dodger you're walking away with uh a
hoodie here we go i got
i got uh oh the the the the comments are
all over the place
oh i got a nuke a nuke is a sleigh a
nuke his lava says he will hit nine
three-pointers wow that is a very very
very bold
statement but it's steph curry it's not
like he probably i mean steph curry he
has a chance at doing it uh i got young
skull says 27 so he's rocking with the
under so shout out to everybody that i
mentioned you guys are all walking away
with hoodies uh remember though please
remember after the game we're gonna hit
up one person and hook you guys up with
a jersey now let's talk major markets
money lines against the spread and
points totals for tonight's game live
let's take a look at the odds liv what
are you seeing here
and what do you like
right off the bat i like over 221 and a
half in the warrior sons matchup these
two teams rank top five in points scored
per game one of those teams the warriors
are leading the league in three pointers
made and like i said earlier two top ten
paced teams i think this is a shootout a
very high scoring game so right off the
bat i really like the over in the
warrior suns matchup
love that love that live actually the
way we know the high-powered offense in
golden state we know what they've been
doing this year and we also know that
the suns have a good team
they got a good offense as well they
like to shoot the ball in phoenix so i
don't dislike your over there live i do
not dislike your over uh let me hop into
the comments before i give my take let
me hop into the comments uh here we go
social dilemma social dilemma says
he says steph is going for 34. shout out
to you i mean even though we we moved
past that i'm giving you a hoodie just
because of the take look love the take i
got the warriors plus three and a half
big bry guy says it's free cash for the
warriors plus three and a half uh
locks underwater his back says 25 for
the jersey but we're not from new jersey
i have no idea what that means oh i
guess he said steph is going for 25
points okay shouts out to you lots
underwater but uh let me jump in here
live let me jump in here the this line
keeps growing
it keeps growing and it keeps and i
don't know why liv i have no reason why
i'm talking about this warriors
plus three and a half but i don't want
the plus three and a half i want the
money line i want the money line the
warriors they've been
they've been playing well they've been
playing really well they've been playing
extremely well the best team in the nba
live i don't see why they're the
underdog i know that they're going to
phoenix and i know that they're it's
going to be a hostile playoff like
environment but
plus three and a half i can see this i
thought this would be a pick em or
something but plus three and a half you
guys know i like value and also i'm
betting with my heart not my head i'm
betting with my heart i'll admit it so
i'm taking the warriors
on the money line uh we talked major
markets now let's talk some player props
let's hop into it we like to play a
little game called
lock
or not i'm gonna put up a prop in the
audience i want the audience to get in
the comments and tell me if it's a lock
or it's not live
are you ready
i am ready i was born ready
i like that let's get right to it then
first up is kd to score over 28 and a
half points in tonight's next knicks
matchup the odds are currently at minus
106.
liv
what do you think is that a lock or is
it not
i'm gonna go with not and it's crazy
that i'm saying that because i never
thought that i would fade kevin durant i
mean he is arguably one of the strongest
scorers in the league right now maybe
even the best however this nets team
you've got some guys that are kind of
finding their groove right now patty
mills is a great example i feel like he
has filled the joe harris shoes from the
three-point line and that takes a little
bit of the pressure off of kd in a game
like this
also lamarcus aldridge is the center and
he's going up against a team on the
knicks that their center right now is
questionable they've got a questionable
robinson and noel so there's a lot of
opportunities for aldridge who has been
scoring pretty decently lately to also
get some buckets so because of guys like
mills and because of guys like aldridge
tonight i think they've got more
opportunities to score and i think it
takes a little bit of the pressure off
of kd not to say he won't have himself a
game that's a pretty high number and i
know he hits it a lot but i don't know
if he has to do all of the scoring work
tonight so i'm actually leaning on the
under
liv that is a very very very interesting
take i like it
but i don't love it because i'm going
the opposite way i'm going the opposite
way we're talking about kevin durant
we're talking about the best player in
the nba
also liv this is the new york match-up
the knicks taking on the nets the
celebrities are going to be there
nationally televised game you don't
think kd's going to show up the walking
bucket
kd is gonna show up he's gonna put up
i say he's going over 30. i think he's
going over 30. he just had 39 in his
last game lift
that hot hand that hot hand of kevin
durant is going to transfer over into
this big time game in new york so i'm
rocking with the over i'm in the
comments though
i'm in the comments because i want to
know what they think i want to know what
they're talking about i got mr pancakes
mr pancakes is in the comments saying
katie is going for 40 bet without it uh
he he's going to bet
anybody he says betting anybody shout
out to you mr pancakes mr mack zero zero
one one says 40 piece for kd he loves to
cook the knicks yes this is a new york
match up liv uh kd is going to show up i
got one more
i got one more
i got one more i see uh
i see sauce 90 sauce 90 says kevin
durant is dropping 30 points shout out
to you sauce uh let's move on next is
patty mills liv you mentioned patty
mills you mentioned that he's been
stepping up
so let's talk about patty mills his
three points made is sitting at over
or under three and a half
do you think the over is a lock or not
live
i think it's a lock paddy mills has hit
this over in four of the last five and
like i said he's really finding his
groove from the 3.9 three-point line and
not to mention he's going up against a
knicks team that currently allows the
fifth most three pointers to their
opponent their perimeter defense has
definitely been their downfall this year
so i think patty mills hits this with no
problem in this new york matchup that
you keep mentioning i'm now terrified of
the under for kevin durant you convinced
me almost out of it but a guy like patty
mills will thrive from the three-point
line up against a knicks team that
struggles to defend the perimeter so i
love it it's a lock
she said it is a lock live you know what
i'm not gonna disagree with you on this
one i'm gonna actually ride the
wavelengths and ride your vibes and uh
patty mills has been bawling lately he
has been balling so i can see him i'll
go make some threes paddy uh let me hop
into the comments let me hop into the
comments and see what they are talking
about i got wm bulls saying the under
don't like those vibes because me and
liv are going with the over but guess
what brother
still gonna give you a hoodie it's the
holidays why not it's the holidays uh
then
vin's oh neal is 68 says has to be over
if the nets want to win i absolutely
agree the nets want to win my boy patty
mills has to show up shout out to
everybody that i just mentioned you are
walking away with hoodies live finally
we have julius randle
at over 30 and a half combined points
and rebounds live the over
the over
is it a lock
or is it not with this one
first of all look at that picture of him
i mean i'd be scared to try to go up
against this guy and get some rebounds
he is looking fit this year my gosh but
i one of my favorite bets last season
especially in the playoffs was julius
randle to get some rebounds typically
you know you lean on his points because
he's kind of the dominant scorer or he
was anyways last year for this knicks
team however we have a questionable
starter
for the center position uh on this next
team so that right there gives them more
opportunities to get boards and he's
going up against a nets team that ranks
bottom 10 in rebounds allowed to their
opponent i don't really worry about his
ability to score in a game like this
like we've talked about a lot of hype
around this game and i absolutely love
the play given the opportunities he has
to get boards tonight as well so i'm i'm
taking the over i think it's a lock
liv is taking the over i actually like
that liv we call julius randle on this
show we call him the other 30. because
we know who 30 is that's 30 steph curry
yes but on the east coast he's the 30
out there and he's deservingly so to be
called the 30 out there in the east
coast uh
we know we we know the rebounds will be
there like you said he's been struggling
to score lately but what have i been
talking about liv
it's the big new york matchup that's
what's going to get my guy julius randle
to score more points tonight he's going
to have to answer the call answer the
bell
it's new york versus new york who's
going to run the city julius
it's up to you man go go get some points
you got to score today so if he scores
we know the rebounds is there so i like
the over i'm in the comments i'm in the
comments right now
giving away one hoodie
uh
let me see i see westbrook 34 says
randall is most likely to go over maybe
in just points big game tonight shout
out to you westbrook 34. you are walking
away with the hoodie i also have uh
jay hearn jay hearn zero uh one zero two
four says over for julius reynolds shout
out to you jay hearn you are also
walking away with the hoodie live
let's move on we love the fanduel same
game parlay around here so br betting
builds a custom
a custom one for everybody
and you guys can ride along with us so
i'm gonna tell you what we're looking at
and i want to hear you guys take in the
comments then tonight on the inside the
nba pregame show chuck yes chuck charles
barkley is going to look at our parlay
and pick his favorite leg last week we
hit three of four legs and missed the
parlay by three points only three points
because the knicks decided to bench
rj barrett the entire fourth quarter
thieves we need to have
a conversation for that uh we're gonna
make up we're gonna make up one this
week liv we're gonna make up one this
week but before
before we get into it i need everyone in
the comments to tell me
what they think of the parlay which leg
is gonna
lose the parlay which leg is the lock of
the parlay uh just just just give me
give me takes on the parlay and liv
guess which team the same game parlay is
on tonight
i got a guess warrior sons you since
you're betting with your heart tonight
that's my that's my guess
you already know you already know what
time it is we betting with our hearts so
we go pick our team you feel me so here
we go let's get right to it let's get
right to it uh starting it off
starting off we call him 30 on this show
we call him 30 on this show 30 we need
you to go get five three pointers this
is like a layup for steph curry he
probably does this in his sleep nightly
he makes five threes in his dreams i'm
pretty sure because he goes out onto the
court and makes five threes like it's
nothing like it's nothing so liv talk to
me do you like
this leg of the parley or do you not
i of course i do i mean steph curry five
plus made threes he's hit this in the
last three it feels wrong to ever fade
steph curry from the three-point line we
know what he can do especially in a game
like tonight where it's potentially a
matchup that we'll see down the line in
the uh western conference championship
game i mean he is going to show out uh i
absolutely love this leg there's no
reason this shouldn't hit
okay okay i've been sensing the good
vibes liv i am sent in the good vibes uh
let's move on to the next one let's move
on to the next one
my guy d book
d book
20 points live you mentioned high
scoring you mentioned shootout
can d book go get 20 tonight
yes absolutely i mean this is this is a
game that devin booker is going to show
up to and do what he needs to do uh 20
points i feel like that's a walk in the
park for him he's had 30 plus points in
the last three games i have a feeling by
half time devin booker's got 13 to 15
points so i could see this prop cashing
in the third quarter uh but yeah i have
no i have no worries about devin booker
getting 20 plus points at all especially
in a game like tonight
love that take with these same games
parlay the earlier that your bet hits
the better because you get to enjoy the
rest of the game so i love
the third quarter let's get d book 20
points take love that lip let's move on
to the next leg though let's move on to
the next leg we talked curry we talked
de-booked let's move on to chris paul i
was kind of skeptical
with this one i was kind of skeptical
with this one i'm not gonna lie but live
talk to me give me some vibes give me
some good vibes uh tell me what you
think of chris paul
going for 10 assists tonight 10 10 or
plus assists tonight
yeah i mean i'm kind of with you in the
sense that this one does make me a
little bit nervous but i don't hate it
at all uh the hard thing about chris
paul is he's hard to get a read on
sometimes he's focusing on scoring other
times he's focused on facilitating the
offense
so you kind of you kind of don't know
what you're gonna get from this guy i
mean it's it's tough to get a read on
what he's gonna bring to a game like
tonight uh but there's no reason it
shouldn't hit he's hit this over in
three of the last five and he is the
point guard so his job is to facilitate
the offense and to feed the ball to a
guy like devin booker so that he can hit
20-plus points so hopefully he does his
job correctly and we don't have to worry
about it
yeah you see like i see dots here i just
see dots and like they're just
connecting each time liv is just telling
me that my parlay is gonna hit so i like
it i like it i like it uh let's move on
to this last leg let's move on to this
last leg
draymond green now liv
draymond he's almost i won't call him a
walking triple double but he's almost a
walking triple double so with that being
said
you know in order to get a triple-double
you need double digits
in whatever it is whatever category it
is so he's sitting at six rebounds here
liv this
what do you think this is kind of low
for draymond i think he can get this
easy
yeah i mean draymond is not the type of
guy that i would stick at the
three-point line and depend on him to
score and because i think this is gonna
be such a fast-paced game i think he
just needs to focus on defense he's hit
this over in three of the last five and
i have always said when draymond green
prioritizes something that is not
scoring whether it be assists or
rebounds or blocks or steals he is so
dangerous the second i feel like he
starts prioritizing scoring i think he
loses the danger about him so he needs
to stay under the basket grab the boards
and be a dominant force on defense and
if he does that which i believe he will
this will cash and i think the warriors
will win i do
let's
go let's go
so liv is filling my parlay she's
filling my parlour and she filling my
bed tonight my warriors win money line
so i'm i'm i'm feeling all i'm feeling
the vibes live i am feeling the vibes
i'm feeling good uh let's pull this
ticket up we got to see how much money
we gonna win when we put this down you
feel me uh we go put a hundred dollars
down and walk away with 46. so that's
faux hunted and some change right there
liv uh
greater parley lift before i get in the
comments what are you grading the br
betting parlay
you know i'm going to give it a solid a
minus and the only reason i'm not giving
it an a plus is because
i explained that it's hard to get a read
on a guy like chris paul
he'll give us one or the other sometimes
scoring or assist tonight we need those
assists so if he can show up i'm going
to feel really good but a minus just
because of that one policies prop that's
making me a tiny bit nervous but
otherwise i think it's a solid parlay
and this is going to be a very exciting
and electric game tonight i believe it
yes yes yes love the vibes live i'm just
filled with sunsets in my heart because
of the vibes of this show i feel like
that i'm going to win every bet tonight
let's go you got to manifest it you have
to manifest it i'm in the comments right
now
i'm giving away hoodies liv
but i'm not only giving away hoodies i'm
giving away a jersey here
so i will give away the jersey first
and i see money line killer moneyline
killer says easy money right there
booker can get
24 points easily she is riding with our
parlay so shout out to you moneyline
killer you are walking away
with the jersey of your choice liv i am
not done in the comments
i'm not done in the comments because i
want to give away more hoodies i got
i have
social dilemma social dilemmas in the
comments saying
he he's saying he's he's rocking with
our parlay shout out to you social
dilemma i got cj prince says
i'm in live parlay looks good cp
uh may be tough he said i'm with you liv
so
the cp the cp uh assist may be tough but
the parley looks good shout out to you
cj prince i got one more one more jj
mark 10 30 says manifest in the hoodie
right now greg and guess what brother
you manifested correctly because you are
walking away with a hoodie live you see
how you see how it goes on our show
people manifest they get what they want
they give us good takes they get what
they want they mention they like your
plays they get what they want they
mention winners only please they get
what they want you know it's just we're
just we're just in a giving mood here
it's the holidays why not
um we've been talking about this though
we've been talking about the svena songs
team
facing the golden state warriors tonight
but
the suns are currently on a 16 game
winning streak but they are the fourth
favorite to win the nba finals
i need you guys to get in the comments
and tell me if the phoenix suns can win
it all and if not if not tell me which
team you guys think is going to go all
the way let's take a look at the odds
phoenix currently sitting at plus 900
live is that good value and
what are your favorite bets on the board
right now
well i'll start with the suns and
whether or not it's good value yes the
suns are hot right now but i have a hot
take to accompany them being hot right
now they are a good team they're a solid
team but we saw this last season in the
playoffs they're a young team with a lot
of talent and i feel like the only thing
standing in their way is the chemistry
that can get them through that playoff
pressure when it comes to playoffs and
really making a deep run it's those
veterans that always come out on top
that leads me to my next point the
warriors have been here before they have
vets in steph and draymond that know how
to handle that playoff pressure and keep
the chemistry within the team when
things get tough down the road in the
playoffs also this warriors team is
currently scoring at the second highest
rate and allowing the fewest points to
their opponent so they are dangerous on
both sides of the ball and they don't
even have their full team on the court
yet so if that doesn't terrify you for
the potential of this warriors team i
don't know what will i gotta ride with
the warriors at plus 600 right now i
don't think the suns have what it takes
just yet in terms of what they can do in
the playoffs they've got the talent but
they need that chemistry and they need
that maturity to handle that pressure
and i just don't think they're there yet
but i do think the warriors are there so
i'm gonna take the warriors at plus 600.
love
your take liv love your take
i know this is your first show i know
this is your first show but the very
first show of this season the very first
show of this season
we had the same question we we were
asked who would win it all this season
and liv
i gave the people plus 1200 the golden
state warriors
about two weeks ago we asked the same
question they asked us who's going to
win the nba finals and once again i gave
the people
the golden state warriors and now today
liv your first show here we're so
thankful to have you
they're asking us this question again
who should be favored to win it all
who's going to win the golden state
warriors is who i'm picking uh liv you
mentioned it they're getting the rich is
getting richer the rich is getting
richer they already got one of the most
high-powered offenses in the league
and they're just gonna get better when
klay thompson and james wiseman comes
join the team so uh i'm rocking with the
warriors man if it ain't broke don't fix
it i told y'all at the beginning of the
season and it ain't been broke so we
ain't fixing it and we go continue to
rock with the golden state warriors to
win this year's championship but let me
hop in the comments live because i gotta
see what the people are talking about in
the comments
i got enderman enderman's in the
comments saying got the strength in
numbers gift you know what that means
that means he's rocking with the golden
state voice shout out to you enderman
jj mark 10 30 says warriors will win
because steph is the best player on the
floor unguardable winners only
manifesting a jersey
come back next week or come back on
sunday brother you can get that jersey
uh love your take you're walking away
with the hoodie uh
w and bull w in bull says the suns
rocking with the suns love that take i
mean i don't love the take but i i
respect the tank because it's different
than what me and liv said so that's why
i respect it uh here we go i got one
more in me i got one more in me
money muncher phoenix cannot make it
past the wares who will take it all the
way claims coming back and he will seal
the deal so shout out to you money
muncher10 you are walking away with a
hoodie
live
i think it's time to get on the plot
here i i i think it's time to get on up
out of here liv
uh
thank you guys i just want to thank you
guys for tapping into the group chat
presented by fanduel remember what you
learned today
the 3x2 it's a lock we're sprinkling it
on both games
steph over is easy that thing is cashing
it's steph curry it's only sitting at
what 29 and a half what stephen curry
get on fanduel tell our same game parlay
liv likes it she loves it so
tail our same game parlay and tune in to
tonight's nba pre-game show to see chuck
pick his favorite leg on our parlay
we'll be back next week giving out more
hoodies giving out more jerseys giving
out more locks and if you won a hoodie
today if you want a jersey today br
betting will dm you not greg not liv b r
betting will dm you
thanks to liv for bringing her a game
today thank you to liv for bringing her
a game today
actually i i'm feeling so generous liv i
got the red on you know it's the
christmas colors december is it's coming
it's it's i think it's tomorrow uh
i'm gonna give away another hoodie i'm
just gonna hop in and just give away
uh i see eddie on the go eddie
season of getting eddie on the go says
it's going to be warriors versus bucks
and the warriors are going to take it
all so shout out to you eddie on the go
thank you for your take thank you for
sticking around to the end you see what
happens when you stick around till the
end you will be rewarded uh make sure
you guys get on fanduel ride with us
follow us on social follow me follow liv
follow br bending oh fanduel
alongside live moods i'm greg ivory
we are leaving the group chat
peace
[Music]
[Music]
you